y
[Música]
el primer ministro israelí benjamín
netanyahu calificó de vergonzoso a la
decisión del consejo de derechos humanos
de investigar las presuntas violaciones
de los mismos cometidas durante los 11
días de enfrentamientos con el grupo
islamista hamás que celebró la
aprobación de la resolución la alta
comisionada para los derechos humanos de
la onu michelle bachelet habló de
posibles crímenes de guerra
en un discurso pronunciado en el
memorial de kigali el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón aseguró en ruanda que
reconocía la responsabilidad de francia
en el genocidio de 1994 en ese país
africano afirmó que francia no fue
cómplice pero permitió durante demasiado
tiempo que el silencio prevaleciera
sobre la verdad
bashar al-assad ganó un cuarto mandato
como presidente y seguirá gobernando
siria durante siete años más tras
obtener el 95.1 por ciento de los votos
en las polémicas elecciones
presidenciales celebradas el día
miércoles en los territorios bajo su
control buena parte de la comunidad
internacional ha calificado los comicios
como una farsa
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 sirve a blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos esta
noche el consejo de derechos humanos de
la onu aprobó la creación de una
comisión internacional encargada de
investigar presuntos crímenes cometidos
durante el reciente intercambio bélico
entre israel el grupo hamas en gaza que
duró 11 días y donde murieron más de 250
personas la gran mayoría palestinos la
resolución fue aprobada con 24 votos a
favor 9 en contra y 14 abstenciones la
medida fue rechazada por el gobierno
israelí que la calificó de vergonzosa e
insistió en su derecho a defenderse y
advirtió que no cooperará representantes
de hamás por su parte en dieron la
bienvenida a esta resolución
es un día vergonzoso para el consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu que no solo
difama a una democracia que intenta
proteger a su pueblo sino que encubre a
una brutal organización terrorista que
ataca indiscriminadamente a civiles
israelíes y que abusa de civiles
palestinos usándolos como escudos
humanos jamás acoge con satisfacción la
decisión del consejo de derechos humanos
de la onu de investigar los crímenes de
guerra cometidos por las fuerzas de
ocupación contra la franja de gaza y
jerusalén lo que ha sucedido en la
franja de gaza es un crimen de guerra en
toda la regla y que el mundo pudo ver
por televisión al ies que previamente la
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet dijo
que los ataques hacia casa siembran
dudas sobre el cumplimiento de israel
sobre los principios de distinción y
proporcionalidad en la ley humanitaria
internacional y que podrían constituir
crímenes de guerra en alusión a hamás
dijo que también es una violación de la
ley internacional ubicar recursos
militares en zonas civiles densamente
pobladas o atacar desde ellas veamos el
informe de rodrigo se dan
la sombra de los crímenes de guerra se
cierne sobre gaza en medio de las
negociaciones por el alto el fuego entre
israel y hamás
michelle bachelet alta comisionada de la
onu para los derechos humanos sembró la
duda sobre la legalidad de los ataques
de israel en gaza
si se encuentra que fueron en
discriminados y desproporcionados en su
impacto a civiles y objetivos civiles
esos ataques podrían constituir crímenes
de guerra o unas afirmaciones que se
apoyan en los principios de distinción y
proporcionalidad establecidos en el
derecho internacional humanitario' queda
prohibido lanzar un ataque cuando se ha
de prever que cause incidentalmente
muertos y heridos entre la población
civil daños a bienes de carácter civil o
ambas cosas que sean excesivos en
relación con la ventaja militar concreta
y directa prevista estos son los
argumentos que aporto bachelet
a pesar de las afirmaciones de israel de
que muchos de estos edificios se
albergaban a grupos armados o se
utilizaban con fines militares no hemos
visto pruebas al respecto aunque
israel tomó una serie de precauciones
los ataques aéreos en esas zonas
densamente pobladas dieron lugar a un
alto nivel de víctimas mortales y
heridos civiles y sant lluís
las críticas se extendieron también al
lanzamiento de cohetes por parte de
hamás que podrían suponer igualmente una
violación del derecho internacional
humanitario por otro lado también es una
violación de la ley humanitaria
internacional establecer activos
militares en áreas densamente pobladas
por civiles o lanzar ataques desde éstos
y recibir en áreas
entretanto ambas partes acordaron acudir
la semana próxima a el cairo para sentar
los términos de la tregua mediada por
egipto se espera asimismo la
participación de la autoridad nacional
palestina designada por eeuu para
tramitar los fondos de reconstrucción de
gaza y el presidente de francia me de
manera una corona admitió desde ruanda
la responsabilidad de su país en el
genocidio de 1994 que dejó unos 800 mil
muertos aunque el mandatario no
pronunció claramente una disculpa el
presidente ruandés paul kagamé aplaudió
las palabras de su
luego francés mientras que desde la
principal asociación de supervivientes
se lamentaron que no haya habido una
solicitud explícita de perdón el informe
secuenciales
más que palabras macrón llegó a ruanda
con el objetivo de normalizar unas
relaciones marcadas por el papel de
francia en el genocidio de los tutsis lo
más esperado una disculpa por parte de
un país que está acusado de hacerse el
de la vista gorda ante un gobierno que
de manera sistemática mató a 800.000
personas desde un memorial con los
restos de más de 250.000 víctimas macrón
admitió responsabilidad de francia en la
masacre pero sin una disculpa clara
soy un [__] si leen uy
son aquellos quienes han atravesado la
noche los que pueden quizás perdonar y
darnos el regalo del perdón
wow
sus palabras fueron algo más valioso que
una disculpa annápolis de higüey fueron
la verdad
speaking de fruit hablar de la verdad es
arriesgado pero uno lo hace porque es lo
correcto
it is right según un informe ordenado
por el propio macro y publicado en marzo
por una comisión de historiadores
francia tiene una abrumadora
responsabilidad por no haber previsto la
masacre es una herida aún abierta para
los supervivientes del genocidio que
esperaban esas palabras de perdón aunque
pública fascismo no podemos olvidar tan
fácilmente hay que ser claros ellos
participaron ellos ayudaron si no era el
momento de decir perdón claramente sin
irse de un lado a otro con el ánimo de
fortalecer estas frías relaciones de los
últimos años macrón anunció que
designará un embajador en ruanda el
primero desde 2015 y el presidente sirio
bashar al-assad obtuvo una aplastante
victoria en unas cuestionadas elecciones
presidenciales en las que obtuvo el 95.1
por ciento de los votos según fuentes
gubernamentales de esta manera el
presidente de quien se encuentra en el
poder desde el año 2000 obtendrá un
cuarto mandato tras unos comicios
calificados como ilegítimos y falsos por
occidente y la oposición siria en el
exilio desde el líbano de tell bonet
los detalles va a ser al asad ha
revalidado un cuarto mandato de siete
años en unas elecciones en las que ya se
anunciaba su victoria antes de darse a
conocer los resultados al asad ha
reforzado su poder en siria pero ha
perdido legitimidad de cara a la
comunidad internacional que no reconoce
estos comicios porque no cumplen con las
expectativas de la resolución 22 55 del
consejo de seguridad que sienta las
bases de una nueva constitución y de
unas elecciones libres bajo supervisión
de observadores internacionales al asad
se enfrenta a un país devastado por 10
años de guerra y profundamente dividido
rusia y eran son sus principales aliados
en la guerra pero a la hora de la
reconstrucción siria necesita cientos de
miles de millones de dólares que vendrán
a través de las ayudas internacionales y
para poder ayudar a siria la comunidad
internacional necesita confiar en el
presidente asad que no ha dado muestras
de creer
el país a un proceso democrático sin
garantías de volver los 5 millones de
refugiados que están en países como el
líbano no podrán regresar a siria y
vamos ahora hasta américa latina porque
con 69 votos en contra 31 a favor el
senado de colombia rechazó la moción de
censura en contra del ministro de
defensa diego molano el funcionario de
señalados por el despliegue de la fuerza
pública contra las manifestaciones
antigubernamentales que mañana cumplirá
un mes y en las que han muerto más de 40
personas presuntamente a manos de la
policía según denuncian organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos los
bloqueos en las vías producto de estas
movilizaciones ciudadanas han golpeado
la economía del país y según varios
sectores se estima que las pérdidas son
superiores a los 10 millones de pesos
que equivalen a unos 2 mil 800 millones
de dólares
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buena noche y hasta pronto
[Música]
siga todas las noticias del deporte con
france24